alrighty everyone today is dc fandom
which i have actually been super excited
about
uh i'm a little bit late to catching up
on some of the stuff that came out today
had some crappy family news so it took
the day to you know deal with that um
right now we are going to jump right
into watching the batman trailer if you
don't know me i am a massive batman fan
um my apartment is full of batman
memorabilia i have a tattoo the list
goes on but i thought that i would also
because it's pretty short two minutes
and 50 seconds will also catch up on
some of the other dc fandom trailers
that drop today that i missed so this
video is going to be all about catching
up on the movies and then i'll do a
separate one for the video games and um
yeah i'm super excited across the board
this feels like a nice way to cheer
myself up got a nice cup of tea here
let's go also i want to note i have not
had anything spoiled for me i've not
even really seen anything so
i'm going in fresh and immediately this
looks like cyberpunk
you've got the synth on it too look at
you guys
oh is that dano
the riddler is it
very good
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
he looks good
this is such a dark trailer
[Music]
he's doing a voice
hmm
i can take care of myself oh
if this continues it won't be long
before you have nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
god she's so hot
who are you under there
oh my god
oh
oh my god
oh batman you could have just killed a
man you got to be careful with that
that's against the rules
oh my
[Music]
that
is a
very good trailer um it is very
cinematic i mean that i think actually
is
paul downer who has like
he
i just saw him in one movie and i was
like oh my god this dude is amazing like
so amazing that i couldn't stop watching
him and he wasn't the lead character
um
he's amazing and i wonder if that's
going to be like a um
joker dark knight situation where he
intentionally gets caught there were
some other things in here i mean this is
really cinematic look at that
who are you under there
this
is so cool
i'm vengeance oh my god
i like his voice i like what he's doing
with his voice um that's obviously like
a really specific choice everybody makes
this is the only thing i don't love
um
i'm absolutely not in the camp of of
people who don't like robert pattinson i
think he's a really good actor um
clearly he did twilight
and hated it and then went to work on a
bunch of largely indie movies and i
think he's really good and i totally
think he can play batman
i just don't
love the look of this bruce i don't
really care if the movie does something
different with bruce wayne i don't need
it to be the exact same as the comics
in any way if i'm seeing a different
medium and it's it's in the same world
and i think that that's cool that
definitely is enough to excite me but no
part of me needs it to be a one-to-one
i'm not the kind of fan who gets upset
basically um when something isn't exact
and i think maybe they could make it
work if what they do or what they are
doing with this is having him be like
eccentric
nerd billionaire that's the only way i
think it works he's like a little bit
emo or whatever
but is essentially
you know an eccentric outsider emo bruce
wayne um which is a very different
character
and the only thing that doesn't really
go hand in hand there is that in theory
he's supposed to be pretty ripped
because he's also batman but
i mean i'm fine with it i'm okay with it
um it doesn't he just doesn't look
like i'd expect i'm not i'm not loving
the appearance right now i don't care
what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
i the action looks great the way this
whole thing is lit
like beautiful lighting like
constant change of tone maybe we're not
so different
i think this is a really good trailer
and it's got me super hyped
all right next up we're going to take a
look at the flash this is a first look
teaser trailer looks pretty short
um oh hang on i need to make sure we've
got the right quality settings here we
do okay
[Music]
it just looks kind of bad
greetings i love him i love him
we're very excited to show you the movie
uh
and we can't yet because we're still
making it we wanted to show you a teaser
but we can't because we don't have
enough material to make a teaser yet
we can't make a trailer
but we do have this small sneak peek
that my maestro andy and i have put
together that we really hope you'll
enjoy and i will see you in theaters
later next year or more importantly
you will see me
tell me something i appreciate the
canada that they're like hey nobody
anywhere you want right
any timeline
any universe
[Music]
this looks very moody
it is a dc movie
why do you want to stay
fight to save this one
you change the future
hmm
oh
are you in
that's really exciting that's super cool
um and yeah i really like ezra i know
that like some people don't love him so
much but i think he's awesome and i like
his take on on flash as well okay next
up
we're gonna do shazam 2 fury of the gods
let's go
it seems stylish so far
[Music]
hello my name is zachary levi i should
have a little tag and i play shazam
we all established something very
special on the first movie and i did
really enjoy the first movie it was like
we've expanded on that hot felt fun
is it helen mirren with being
superheroes this is where you hang out
with your superhero friends isn't it
i recognize that kid too
we have mythological creatures minotaurs
harpies and dragons
that's going to be pretty expensive
upgrades we got an upgrade huge upgrade
in the suit bigger everybody's hot
that's great for us
athens to philadelphia we go from the
rock of eternity and the library of
eternity to the realm of the gods so we
get to go to environments that were
never explored in the first phone
we have it all three two one
shazam fury of the gods
takes the excitement and the action
to a whole new level
it's going to be more of a spectacle
it's fun all around
you're in store for a treat
so not a ton there not a ton 2023 good
to know i guess um i don't trust any
release dates anymore or even really
take note of them because things keep
getting pushed because it covered
obviously or just get pushed anyway um
so this really states mean nothing to me
but um yeah this looks like a lot of
action obviously yeah not not a ton to
take away but
helen mirren and hespera is also very
cool
for anyone who knows much about greek
mythology alrighty this is the last one
i'm pretty sure at least let me know if
i've missed anything um this is the
black atom trailer
this looks like a video game
is this a video game and i just think
it's a movie
it looks like house of ashes
the the supermassive
game
hmm
very moody again
oh my
you uh model combated that man
that's very cool
ooh i expected more than that okay
that's also next year apparently was
what it's slated for
um hey
that looked cool as hell
and yeah i'm pretty sure that i'm now
caught up on all the big movie trailers
from dc i'll also drop my reactions to
any of the video game stuff
in a little bit might wait a few hours
i'm not sure
let me know if i missed anything i'm not
sure i might have um loved the batman
trailer i thought it was really cool now
i am very interested to see the
direction they go with bruce wayne he
doesn't look like any of our past bruce
wayne's and i'm all right with it but uh
we'll see what they do it does
definitely look like it's a unique take
and i'm very curious thank you all for
watching i'll see you next time bye